JOE SALISBURY: OK,
so you have an app.
Now, how can make the
right decisions to ensure
it's successful and has a
sustainable business model?
Hi, I'm Joe Salisbury,
Product Specialist for AdMob.
I make sure developers'
feedback gets heard.
And I work closely with our
product and engineering teams
to buildout new features and
get developers, like you,
onboard to beta test those,
and get them to market quicker.
We're excited to share
this series of videos
to help you better
understand the ads
ecosystem, the different
business models for mobile,
and how you can make the
most revenue from your app.
To get things started,
in this first video,
we'll be looking at the
big picture-- focusing
on making the right
decisions early on to ensure
that your app is successful.
To be successful on
mobile, you first
need to determine what
goals are important to you
and understand what key
performance indicators you
should be looking at
to make sure you're
building a sustainable
business model.
This involves understanding
user behavior through feedback
in analytics, knowing how
to get your app discovered,
and connecting with
global audiences
through localization
of your app.
Let's start with user behavior.
It's critical to focus
on user experience
to keep your users engaged,
and constantly improving
your app by measuring
your user's behavior
and listening to their
feedback over time.
Your users will be
happy and they'll
keep returning to your app.
To get there, you'll
need to pay attention
to how people are using
your app and where
you might be losing them.
There are a few ways
you can do this.
Keep a close eye on feedback
and your apps ranking.
Are you meeting expectations
and your users needs?
Understand user behavior
through analytics.
We'll discuss this more in a
detailed video about Google
Analytics and AdMob.
Understand different
types of users and segment
accordingly to their behavior.
For example, if
you have a gaming
app, and a user is stuck
on the first level.
You might want to
provide tips on how they
can beat that and keep playing.
Next, you need to know how to
acquire new users for your app.
How do you get discovered by
users and what key metrics
should you keep an eye on?
Start by looking at
distribution channels.
Think multi-platform.
You'll need to be available
in multiple distribution
platforms, the big
ones, Android and iOS.
Once you're in the store,
how do you maximize your apps
discoverability?
Spend some time carefully
crafting your app store
listing.
Focus on making those
first two lines impactful.
High-quality screenshots and
videos will go a long way.
Also, as small as it may seem,
the quality of your app icon
makes a huge impression.
An icon is a graphic that takes
up a small portion of screen
real estate and provides
quick intuitive representation
of an action, a
status, or an app.
Your app may be installed
on a variety of devices.
And make sure your icon looks
great on all those devices
by providing
multiple icon sizes.
Next, it's important to
think global and act local.
The key is to deliver your
tailored, localized versions
of your app so you can connect
with users all over the world.
Why?
According to a survey,
53% of Chinese respondents
and more than one third of
Japanese and South Korean users
felt apps they were using were
poorly adapted to their needs.
And 25% to 30% of
users discounted
app usage because of it.
And according to 10% of
users in China and Japan,
even if the app was great,
they would stop using it
if it wasn't
adequately localized.
So adjuster your user
interface, and make
sure you're
culturally sensitive.
You can use Google's
easy-to-use translation tools
to adjust the
language of your app
to meet those needs
of those users.
List your app in the Play
Store in translated versions,
and localize the graphic
assets, so those users
can see what their app will
look like in their language.
You also need to keep in
mind reviews and ratings
when considering
user acquisition.
This user feedback
is an important part
of your product listing and goes
a long way in attracting users.
The key rule is to
improve your ratings is
to make every attempt so
that unhappy users can
reach you and express their
concerns directly to you.
And so that happy users
can easily leave a review
on the app store.
You'll need to listen to
what your users are saying
and answer them as
fast as possible,
to thank them for
writing you, and to let
them know you're working,
or will be working,
on resolving those issues
they have with your app.
Don't ask for reviews too soon.
Do it at the right
time, and to users who
seem to be enjoying your app.
For example, if they
just want to game
against three of their
friends, give them
the chance to
share their victory
and love your app
on social media.
Or, if they just
leveled up in your game,
encourage them to rate you
then, when they're feeling good.
Another thing to
pay attention to,
where are your
users coming from?
Analyze your traffic
sources and use
that data to make
decisions about where
to put your resources
for the most impact.
Really want to get noticed?
Invest in advertising
your app and see
how well different
acquisition channels perform.
Then, adjust your
strategy accordingly.
We'll go into more detail on
ads later in the video series.
So now you have a
good idea of what
it takes to build a solid
user base of engaged fans.
But let's take a step
back for a moment,
and think about your
strategy for making money.
How will you get
the money to invest
in building that audience?
It's definitely a bit of a
chicken and egg problem, right?
But if you build
and launch an app
without a clear profit
plan from the beginning,
your chances of
success are slim.
Don't worry though,
we'll get exactly
into how you can monetize
your app later on.
Combining different
revenue streams will likely
maximize your overall revenue.
We'll devote an entire section
to this a little bit later.
There, we'll talk about
freemium, premium,
and other business models.
Thanks for watching
these videos and enjoy
the rest of the topics.